[Music]
a cdc advisory committee will meet today
to decide whether to continue the pause
on johnson and johnson's single-dose
coronavirus vaccine
yesterday you'll recall the agency and
the fda said they would take a closer
look at any potential link between the
vaccine and a rare blood clotting
disorder
more than seven million doses have
already been administered in the united
states
blood clots were reported in six women
between the ages of 18 and 48
one of those women died our doctor tara
narula joins us now with the details
and she'll answer some of our viewer
questions as well about vaccine safety
dr
narula good morning to you i i think
right off the top
were you surprised by this decision by
the fda and the cdc
let me be clear in saying i think this
was absolutely the right decision and
all of the officials yesterday really
saying this is taken
out of an abundance of caution with a
hope that this
pause will be days to a week and the
reality is we need to put perspective on
this number one this is extremely rare
it's a one in a million chance of course
those numbers might change
but still very rare and number two at a
time in our country when we've talked
about
lack of transparency and lack of faith
in our federal government this is a
signal
that we are doing the right thing we are
putting the safety
of americans first and the health as a
number one priority
the pause is really giving time for
three things it's giving time for
doctors to
appropriately diagnose report and treat
these conditions should they find them
number two it's giving time for
the cdc to evaluate if there are more
cases that we haven't picked up
on and number three for the expert
committee of the cdc
to meet and decide what are the next
steps going to be
and those really are number one it gets
taken off the market
two it gets kept on the market with some
provisions like maybe it's used only in
older individuals or in certain
categories
or three they say this is really not
that consequential
and we leave it as is yeah you're right
of course this is a sign of the process
working and i hope people take that
message away
you worry that they won't however and so
i'm concerned and i wonder if you share
that concern that this could slow down
the rate of vaccination in this country
and thereby slow
slow down our return to normalcy
well i certainly hope that's not the
case and we know that about 180 million
doses of pfizer and moderna have been
administered
and not one of these cases has been seen
so certainly
americans should feel reassured that at
least with those vaccines that are
readily available now
that there should not be any incidents
we haven't seen any of this particular
rare condition
and hopefully we will get to the bottom
of what's going on with johnson and
johnson soon but
we really do need people to take the
vaccines if they can the ones that are
available that we know are safe and
effective
yeah but people are even now more
nervous tara i know you get that too but
i've got a viewer question here she
asked
i got the johnson johnson vaccine what
should i be looking for
in terms if what should i be looking for
if i have a blood clot
good question great question so if the
vaccine was administered over a month
ago the risk of this condition is
extremely rare and probably
not really an issue if the person
received the vaccine within the previous
three weeks we know that the
median day of onset of this condition
occurred about nine days
then certainly they should be looking
for things like headache a headache
that's severe and persistent
abdominal pain nausea vomiting leg pain
or swelling or shortness of breath or
chest pain do you know why women that
should prompt them to call their doctor
do you know about why women are affected
and is there a certain ethnic
we don't know that but um certainly when
you look at what's happened in europe
with the astrazeneca we also saw
predominance of women
we will need to evaluate these cases
more to figure out is there some
underlying condition that predisposed
these women that we don't know about
we know that there were cases in men
in europe with that astrazeneca vaccine
so there may be more cases that come out
here in fact
dr shuket yesterday after the press
conference mentioned that there was one
man
in the j j trial that now and
retrospectively may have had a similar
situation so it may be genetics and
hormones playing into it as well
all right tara thank you very much of
course we'll all stay on top of this
as i know you will too thanks a lot